what a year 2020 has been there's really
no way to sum it up
but we got the privilege to launch this
show this incredible show
[Music]
the turbulence of the year we persevered
with the most
amazing crew and that's how it really
all happened
it's been such an honor for me to be a
part of this
team i'm so grateful to be
in this family it's been amazing to
watch the show evolve from
its conception last year to our
development
this summer to our launch this
fall please welcome drew barrymore
we hit the ground running just ready and
hoping to meet this moment and since
then we've been able to have
intimate and enlightening conversations
with some of
all of our favorite celebrity guests i
love
you kristen bell i love you too
hi this is the first time we're actually
meeting in person
truly
you have a talk show i know
henry winkler
congratulations on this this is the
greatest you're going to make the whole
country happy
sometimes things got a little weird hey
plus caterpillars
enjoy the spotlight while it lasts
like random
20. like
real weird
i love you oh sherry
sometimes things got a little messy
why just do it do it do it do it
and on occasion things got a little
emotional
they heard your incredible story and
they are giving us
um enough asus chromebooks for every
single student and teacher
at eton elementary
the home depot foundation is going to
pay off your mortgage
in fall
and cat what are you thinking of the
review
[ __ ] two he's one of my favorite
humans
he's brought more to my life than
most people honestly i'm this is just
i'm freaking out it's david sedaris
but i'm supposed to be
i'm supposed to be freaking out so i so
appreciate you being that way
and some of my personal idols i am
having a true
pinch me moment right now because one of
my biggest dreams
is actually coming true oh my gosh
the one and only marie kondo and her
interpreter mikey oh my god
and we've been together despite being
apart i feel like i'm on star trek or
[Music]
[Applause]
something
we also resurrected some of my favorite
characters this year
that was so fun i have a very special
co-pilot today
it's josie geller hi
lucy good morning it's me henry
hi drew sheila from santa clarita
and we had a blast just scrambling the
news we
all right the built-in bra pads
to a swimsuit these ruffle my feathers
get ready for your heart to swell and
maybe even burst on this one
we wanna uh support in every way that we
can so
chris miller and i called our friend
jared margolis at payless shoes
and they're gonna donate 500 pairs of
shoes to your organization
today i love this show so much
and i'm so unbelievably thankful for
this opportunity
and for all the good this year has
brought and it has brought so much good
and me and our team are already dreaming
up all the incredible possibilities that
we could do
in 2021 but none of it matters unless
you're there
so we hope to see you there
you